[Music]
37 year old leo who prefers using a
pseudonym for privacy reasons
was a marketing director at an internet
startup in beijing
until she got pregnant in 2017
on the second day after i learned that i
was pregnant i told the company about
the situation
in two days the company sent me on a
business trip to shanghai and shenzhen
for about a week
when i came back from the business trip
i found out the company had recruited
the appropriate candidate for my
position who would be employed shortly
after hiring a candidate for this
position they demoted me
and dismissed me stopped paying my
salary and closed my work mailbox
she is still deep in a legal battle to
win her unpaid salary and an apology
from the company
my first appeal was a labour arbitration
in 2017 for labour disputes
from 2017 to 2021 it has been more than
four years
nearly five years i think this process
has been very long and torturous
leo is part of growing gender
discrimination in the workplace in china
a side effect of beijing's push to boost
birth rates
although there are no official
statistics lawyers and labor activists
say there's been a notable pickup in
cases of employers declining to give
jobs and promotions to women since
china's one child policy officially
ended in 2016.
currently chinese women make up 40
of the total labor force however women
face a big
big glass selling when they try to climb
climb up the
corporate ladder and at the hiring stage
women are also facing difficulties when
job posting explicitly or implicitly say
that
they prefer men over women to address
the problem the government in 2019
laid out more specific rules to ban
discriminatory practices in the hiring
process
even though china has one of the highest
female labor force participation rates
in asia
women there are still expected to be the
primary caregiver of children due to the
lack of child care services
another thing is women currently needs
to sacrifice their own career to
give birth to baby china is very special
in a sense that
it provides very extensive maternity
belief to mother
well it does not provide any states a
national level parental before father
that means
when when a woman decides to be a mom
she will need to take months away from
work and she when she come back she may
only face
more discrimination than before
in leo's case a beijing court ruled in
favor of the company in december
and rejected her appeal earlier this
month
the court accepted the company's
argument that each of its actions was a
normal business decision
and decided there was not enough
evidence to prove discriminatory
intentions
but she remains hopeful
now our country has opened up to three
children and announced that we will also
support the protection of three children
with corresponding protective measures
this will include the protection of
women's rights so i think in the future
there will be more policies and
regulations protecting the rights and
interests of our women
you